I must say there is a very strange
feeling when there's people that are
watching your video really quickly like
it feels like your art is being
discovered really fast and there's
something that kind of fills you with
feelings of goodness
whether it be dopamine or what-have-you
so in a minute there's been a hundred
and fifty plus people that have watched
the video in one minute
that's pretty fast dissemination of
information around the world and people
watching it which is kind of interesting
these little feelings of virality are
important to talk about because they
have a lot to do with our heart and our
artistic expression but also our
neuroscience and the way that it makes
us feel and that it's important to be
vigilant about the sort of like
subscription to like validation you know
Russell Brand has been talking about
that a lot and I think it's really
important a lot of youtubers and content
creators are going through that tick
stalkers are now going through that so
it's really important to like think
about these types of things and really
pass our time with vigilantly immersing
ourselves in how it makes us feel and
not letting it overcome us and have that
be something that we Mark are like worth
on because human beings completely
transcend social media validation
the feelings of oneness and unity and
communion with the divine and being with
one another
spiritually metaphysically feels like it
transcends social media validation but
also it's understood that that's a part
of the artistic expression being
validated by other people that we are
producing awakening content or
meaningful content or valuable content
to other people so there's this inyoung
duality to it that is important for us
to blow blue talk about more and
understand more and foster the good and
foster the artistic expression as much
as as we can and reduce as much of these
mental health issues as possible so just
a couple quick thoughts you want to see
the number again okay it was one one
eight five right one one eight five last
time so let's switch it back to let's go
to the inbox now we'll go back to my
page yeah one three three three another
hundred and fifty people watched it in
like two minutes
I think I put all them back into
infrastructure that goes on with tic toc
with bike dance the parent company what
they have to do they have to take these
individual profiles and they have to
cycle them across a couple people and
then if those couple people like it or
watch it for long periods of time
they'll cycle it to a couple more people
and so that's the idea of virality is
that the more valuable the content is
initially the first couple of people
it's distributed to the more likely it
goes like a tree up into more and more
branches right and so
the backend infrastructure for all of
this and the way that the algorithms
work is important to be aware of so that
it's not just a big black box but that
we at least fundamentally at a very
surface level understand algorithmically
how these dissemination methods of
creative content work Big Love